Hallo hallo BAU BAU!
It's time for FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning hajimaru yo!
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
I'm not a chihuahua, I'm Fuwawa.
I'm not Fuwawa, I'm Mococo!
Together we are FUWAMOCO!
BAU BAU BAU!
And today we're your hosts of FUWAMOCO Morning!
Take care, Ruffians!
You're awake?
You're awake today!
Maybe not before.
Just barely.
But you're awake!
Thank you for joining us today for our 86th episode!
BAU BAU!
You did it, Mofu!
You're sleepy.
Barely awake.
Well, FUWAMOCO!
FUWAMOCO report!
FUWAMOCO is not sleepy, but we're at the point where we're extra silly.
So this is what FUWAMOCO Morning is gonna be from now on, right?
Yeah.
That's the time of day.
You know, with FUWAMOCO Morning being back, I see a lot of new Ruffians, new face Ruffians.
So!
Old face Ruffians.
Yeah, the old face Ruffians too.
For those that are joining us maybe for the first time today, FUWAMOCO Morning is a short format morning show held every Friday, Wednesday, and Monday.
A.K.A.
FUWAMOCO!
And it's hosted by us.
Our aim is to bring a smile to your face and help you start your day off on the right paw.
Please tweet your thoughts with the hashtag.
Hashtag FWMCMORNING.
Not FUWAMOCO Morning.
Let's all BAU BAU to a brand new FUWAMOCO Morning!
BAU BAU!
Take care of you.
FUWAMOCO-chan.
It's the Wednesday episode of FUWAMOCO Morning.
And that means... What?
There's been... Another Pero Sighting!
I don't... I don't know how to feel because... Ruffians!
Ruffians are happy when Pero's around.
Doesn't look like it today.
I'm happy when... Ruffians are happy.
Well...
Maybe not today, but!
Where was he spotted?
De-den!
Oh!
This was during an eclipse that happened a little while ago.
Did you get to see a Ruffian?
Yeah.
FUWAMOCO.
We didn't.
But, you know, that's okay because we don't really know too much about them.
Yeah.
Going by this sighting, Pero is what causes them.
Well, if he's the one that's in charge of them, then, you know, it's nice that he returns the world back to normal.
Mine's true.
Actually, you know, I wasn't so sure about eclipses, so I searched it up, and apparently it's the total or partial obscuring of one celestial body by another.
Ruffians.
Does that mean that Pero is a celestial body?
He is round and moonish, right?
Pero is celestial!
Pero has a celestial body!
Well, we're glad to be able to enjoy the especially unique eclipse.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
Well, Mofi.
You might have saw.
You might have been asleep too.
You might have been asleep.
That's the problem.
You shouldn't have seen.
No, I should have been close.
No, no, yes.
But it was just announced.
FUWAMOCO.
We're gonna be guests on the official hololive channel with Nodoka-san for this special Houno Kyuujitsu show!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
I'm super duper excited for it!
Right now, Ruffians!
Actually, we're taking suggestions and ideas for the show through the whole plus app!
So if you have anything cool that you think we could do or maybe Nodoka-san could ask us, please don't hesitate!
Unfortunately though, we can't access the app from outside of Japan right now.
But!
There may be a few JP Ruffians who are willing to help out and we know you can submit
We can submit your ideas for you!
Teamwork!
Teamwork, right!
It's just a big plan to bring the Ruffians all together.
Thank you for being so kind to each other!
And you know, FUWAMOCO, we're really looking forward to having a bunch of fun on the official channel!
Chat lots with Nodoka-san for the first time too!
Oh, you requested!
BAU BAU!
TQ!
Ruffians, fly to Japan to make suggestions!
Really?
You're being silly, okay?
Just half the weight, maybe.
Yeah.
Oh!
Good things take a little bit of time, right?
Right.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
We hope that you can watch too!
What exciting stuff!
And, well, Ruffians.
Okay.
Do you remember that
February!
There was a big collab that we had!
February is so long ago now, right Moco-chan?
It feels like it.
Oh, you do, you do!
What was it though?
Yeah!
That's right!
We had a karaoke collab with hololive's Chloe-sama and we released a cover of BABYMETAL's Gimme Choco!
Gimme Choco!
Gimme Choco BAU!
BAU BAU BAU BAU!
Yeah, it was a lot of fun being able to sing a bunch of songs together with her.
Yeah.
I know.
The cover song is over on Chloe-senpai's channel, so you might have missed it.
Yeah.
Maybe not!
Because it just hit 1 million views!
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
1 million views!
BAU BAU!
It's kind of crazy to think, you know, we've only been debut for 8 months, but in that time we've already covered 2 BABYMETAL songs!
Thank you!
Lots of exciting things happening!
And, well, Ruffians!
Maybe, you know, we haven't been talking about it a lot or anything, right?
It's okay if you don't know, though.
Don't feel bad.
Well, you might know, but FUWAMOCO are now officially in our new doghouse in Japan here!
We got two amazing computer monitors from HyperX!
BAU BAU BAU!
Thank you!
That's one for each of us Ruffians!
So now our studio looks very professional, very sleek.
And they're so beautiful!
It's almost like a mirror.
A black mirror.
Yeah, when you turn it off you can see yourself!
My ears look nice too.
I look extra fluffy.
But you know, even though I have my own monitor,
It's my own mod.
It is.
That just means I can poke and point and make all the fingerprints I want on it, right?
Right, Ruffians?
Not touchscreen.
But I put the touch in touchscreen.
Yeah.
If you touch it enough, it's touchscreen.
I can't disagree with that.
I don't know, I think... Don't touch!
Use gloves!
I think we should keep these ones nice and... And maybe... Fingerprint free even.
Moco-chan, I have a good strategy for that.
You know the best way to keep things fingerprint clean?
What?
Fingerprint free!
You know, is it to clean them?
No.
It's for you to clean them.
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much!
Thank you!
We might not have beds or a table yet, but we'll be okay.
Cause we have these awesome monitors!
BAU BAU!
No, Fuwawa, you clean!
How about you clean something, huh?
BAU BAU!
Thank you!
You know, there's been a lot of milestones recently.
And today, Ruffians,
Another thing!
Another great thing happened!
I think this counts as a milestone.
It's a milestone.
It definitely is.
Yeah.
You know, it's actually a milestone that you've been asking about quite a bit.
A what?
Yeah, right.
Huh.
Oh?
Wow!
We met our first JP-senpai at the studio!
BAU BAU!
Yeah!
Yeah, and it was just purely coincidence.
But, can you guess who we ran into?
Who was JP-senpai?
I saw it!
Ruffians!
It was Fubuki-senpai!
BAU BAU!
Fubuki-senpai!
Amazing, huh?
We were so so so happy to see her.
She was so cute and fluffy looking.
She was so cute and she just popped out from the corner of the door frame and was like, FUWAMOCO-CHAN!
You know, and Fubuki-senpai was also the first JP-senpai we collaborated with.
And she's always so nice and kind to us, so...
We are just so happy.
Yeah, a lot of FUWAMOCO's first time with Fubuki-senpai.
We really hope that we can learn even more from Fubuki-senpai because we really admire her.
Amazing!
We feel really lucky to play with our canine family.
Can you touch me?
You can.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
BAU BAU!
I know Fubuki-senpai!
She's been playing lots of Lethal Company recently.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU!
It was so much fun playing all together with Koyori-senpai playing Lethal Company!
Yo, she's addicted y'all.
That's okay, we understand too.
BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU BAU B
You know, I'd like to think that, you know, FUWAMOCO, we're pretty straightforward and easy to understand.
But... I guess with how many times we've had this corner, that wouldn't be too hard.
Yeah.
Ruffians!
There's been another misunderstanding.
You know how we talked about the Cheesecake Scam last FUWAMOCO Morning, right?
Right!
Well, it looks like quite a lot of JP Ruffians are worried and apologetic about the whole situation.
There's quite a lot of comments!
Yeah, uh, in case you didn't hear, Moco-chan fell prey to the clutches of a good sales lady pushing her fancy and expensive cheesecakes.
What I wanted was really, I just, I just wanted a place to hide in the rain while we waited for Mighty-chan and, you know, a cheesecake to share while we waited even if it was a bit expensive.
It didn't sound too bad, you know, but we ended up with two
BAU BAU!
She was just really excited.
And she just wanted to promote the cafe's takeout menu.
I don't think people knew about it.
She's passionate about it.
There wasn't many people around and she was probably just happy to have us stop right beside her.
You know what?
Ruffians!
FUWAMOCO!
We don't just go around with our ears and tails in plain sight, okay?
So she wasn't picking on us or taking advantage of us, okay?
She meant well, I'm sure of it.
She was just very excited and pushy.
And we were pushover pups.
Moco-chan was a pushover pup.
Wee.
Anyways, Abyss, do you really think though, out of all discounts, someone would choose to pull that a cheesecake one would be a good idea?
Huh?
We can think of better options, right?
Like if you want to discount people out of money, I don't think you would start up a fancy cafe selling cheesecake, right?
You'd do something a lot more
Scary.
Scary!
It went through the eyes!
You can't think of anything better, huh?
The ring scam.
Oh, like the one where you give it to FUWAMOCO, and then FUWAMOCO eats it, and they're happy.
That one?
That's the scam.
Yeah.
Huh?
Actually, Moco-chan, I'm happy because I asked the Ruffians, can you come up with a better option?
That means that the Ruffians have never thought of such a thing.
Which is good because we were trying to think of other puns.
But we couldn't think of anything.
No.
That's good.
It's good, yeah.
We've fallen for much worse than a cheesecake scam before anyways, so.
BAU BAU!
Moco-chan!
It's the middle of the week.
It's Wednesday.
I don't like Wednesdays.
Really?
Yeah, and you know what?
Wednesday starts with a W. And also, I think the Ruffians, they might have been waiting.
What for?
It's Wednesday.
It's okay, I'm just joking.
FUWAMOCO-chan!
Hi!
Can you give us a little bit more pop to get through the week?
Ruffians!
It's been a while, hi!
Hi.
How've you been good?
Huh?
I know things have been rough, you know.
No FUWAMOCO Morning, no Pup Talks, no regular streams.
It's been strange, right?
Maybe the BAU BAU of y'all slayed up a bit.
Hm?
But you know what?
Despite it all, you powered through!
You're stronger than you think you are, okay?
I know, change is rough.
But sometimes, the momentary discomfort of change is worth the outcome.
Boom.
And now, things are already better, right?
Even if just a bit.
And!
You can do it again!
You can overcome anything else in your way, even if it's a bit scary, okay?
Just like before, it might be rough, it might be uncomfy, but eventually, it'll be over and as good as before!
Even better, okay?
And this time, you'll be stronger.
I mean, you're already super strong, but I'm looking forward to seeing the super duper strong you that's just waiting around the corner.
And I'll work on getting stronger too, okay?
FUWAMOCO!
Let's do it together!
Ganbatte de!
BAU BAU!
It's the middle of the week, but the week has also just started.
So, let's all do our best!
BAU BAU!
Well, next, Moco-chan!
Let's take a look at who the Doggie of the Day is today.
Our Doggie of the Day is... That is Bud!
BAU BAU!
I'm silly Bud just turned 8 a little while ago.
Yeah, you know the first photo here is just three months old.
And the others are not that long ago.
Right!
I guess you're a full-grown puppy too, ohai.
Just like us.
How do you think BAU BAU is?
I think it's a cute BAU BAU.
BAU BAU!
Just like that.
BAU BAU BAU BAU.
Yeah, that's one.
Maybe Bun wants something.
I know that.
Is Ruffian just about to eat?
BAU BAU?
No, Bun, no.
Well, Bud just turned 8 and technically he's no longer a small puppy.
Who says?
Ruffians, do you think Bud's no longer a small puppy?
Poor grown puppy.
Yes, he is.
Well, that's okay because deep down, he's just as silly and playful as he was back then.
I can see it in your eyes.
He wants to play.
I want to play.
Play!
You know, all of us full-grown puppies, we want to play.
Yeah!
And happy birthday, bud!
Happy birthday!
BAU BAU!
Yeah.
Not a small puppy, but still a baby.
BAU BAU!
And today, I went on a walk.
Is that the corner's title?
Is that the title?
I don't think so.
We didn't go for a walk today!
Dance!
It's a beautiful beach sunrise!
Oh, it does look like a boss fight's about to start there, but we're really glad that you're able to go out and go for a nice reflective walk.
You know, it's kind of a little bit of a rough period, you know?
It's okay.
It's always hard, you know, when you come across a big decision in your life.
But, don't worry.
Don't worry, okay?
It'll be fine.
Yeah, you know... I think, you know, even if you decide what you're going to do and what path you're going to go down... Actually, things don't always go as you planned.
Yeah.
But it all works out in the end.
So don't really stress out much about it and just enjoy the journey with all its ups and downs.
That was positive, right?
It's positive.
It all works out.
But it's probably not gonna go how you imagined.
Hopefully that makes you feel better.
I hope.
BAU BAU!
Yeah, it'll all be good eventually.
I don't know about eventually.
It all works out!
It'll be good!
BAU BAU!
And today for a Question of the Day, we have... De-den!
Did y'all store your bunk beds in a unit or at the puppy parent's house?
Or did y'all sell it?
I think we would be very sad if it was gone forever!
Ruffians!
What would you do if we told you we sold it?
Somebody out there might have bought FUWAMOCO's used bunk bed.
Yo, search for it!
Well, Mama Puppy and Papa Puppy have our bunk beds.
Yeah.
This is FUWAMOCO!
Actually, they have all our stuff.
All our stuff.
Yeah, but it's not that much.
No.
Yeah, right.
You know, but it's very hard to get bunk beds for full-blown puppies.
So, we won't let them go that easily.
No.
Yeah.
But if you're wondering, as for sending you to Japan, that's definitely not happening.
No.
When it's built, it stays there.
It stays.
Yeah.
BAU BAU!
You can't sell it.
You sold it to a parrot, no?
No.
We ask, can you please keep this?
BAU BAU!
Thank you so much, Ruffians, for always being a part of FUWAMOCO Morning, and for your submissions!
Maybe you have a doggy!
It hasn't been the day yet.
You could use the hashtag... Hashtag FWMCMORNING!
I'm sure you're talking with us.
Or maybe you go on a really good walk, or you have some kind of question.
Or even better, maybe you have... A FUWAMOCO scoop.
You could use the hashtag FWMC... Scoop?
What?
Maybe you didn't mean to go on a walk, but then you ended up going on a walk.
Thank you, Ruffians, for always being a part of FUWAMOCO Morning with us!
BAU BAU!
As for our next theme, we have...
Donkey Kong Country 2!
BAU BAU BAU!
We beat Donkey Kong Country 1!
We did.
Somehow.
Took us a while.
Took us a lot of screams, a lot of laughter, and a lot of fun.
Broken chair.
Yup, a broken chair.
We're going on to Donkey Kong Country 2.
So we hope you join us, Ruffians!
There's gonna be a lot of
BAU BAU!
Tomorrow, on Tuesday, we're gonna be doing our regular Advent collab.
This time, tomorrow, oh yes, tomorrow.
I'm so confused.
We're playing FUWAMOCO Morning for the first time.
I think Biboo's already beaten us.
She's already played it.
That's okay.
You permitted it.
Okay, Moco-chan.
So we're gonna be doing our best to go viral!
Viral with them!
Yeah?
Yeah.
I'm an all-star now!
Viral, viral, let's go viral!
Viral, viral, let's go!
Hajimaru Sighting!
It's another FUWAMOCO Morning!
It's an evening!
We're gonna be playing Ollie-senpai's brand new visual novel, Days with Ollie, with Ollie-senpai!
We're looking forward to it.
It's going to be our first collab with all these FUWAMOCO.
BAU BAU!
And then Saturday!
It's a FUWAMOCO Rock n' Rawr Party!
It feels like such a long time since we've been able to really just let loose.
BAU BAU!
So we're really looking forward to seeing you lots with your Ruffians!
And then on Sunday for our Doggy Pack.
We have a battle plan that needs to be planned.
So we hope that you'll join us as we kind of think about a bunch of different things, brainstorm, and figure out the best battle plan possible.
BAU BAU!
Thank you, Ruffians!
Thank you!
Thank you so much for joining us today for another FUWAMOCO Morning!
Before we say BAU BAU for now, we'd like to shout out to some of our Extra Special Ruffians today!
Meanwhile, BAU BAU!
Riding my way.
BAU BAU!
Moe-kawaii Ume-chan of hololive English.
Moon in the roof.
BAU BAU!
Umisora.
Stardustman.
BAU BAU!
Getter.
Shield.
BAU BAU!
Pteranodon.
Kenshin Shun.
BAU BAU!
Noise Storm.
Fearless Pandas.
BAU BAU!
And to every other Ruffian out there, we hope you have a howl of a day!
This was today's FUWAMOCO Morning!
FUWAMOCO Morning deshita!
DESHITA!
BAU BAU!